Пане Гармс, якщо США реалізують свою погрозу
і дійсно запровадять санкції проти "Північного потоку-2",
наскільки серйозними будуть наслідки для задіяних німецьких фірм?
Ми вважаємо такі санкції небезпечними не тільки для німецьких фірм,
але й інших країн ЄС.
Ми в принципі вважаємо їх шкідливими для забезпечення німецького і європейського
стабільного енергопостачання в довгостроковій перспективі,
а також з точки зору досягнення наших кліматичних цілей.
Зрозуміло, санкції суперечать німецьким економічним інтересам.
Вони стали б кричущим втручанням в європейський суверенітет, проти чого ми протестуємо.
Наскільки високий у німецьких фірм "больовий поріг"?
Тобто які санкції вони могли би витримати, а які призведуть до виходу з проекту?
Зрозумійте мене правильно, мені не хотілося б обговорювати тему болючості тих чи інших санкцій.
Сподіваємося, що внаслідок діалогу з американською адміністрацією
до санкцій справа не дійде
і не буде необхідності починати нову торгову війну.
Але попри це, що станеться, якщо проти укладальників труб
або інших спеціалізованих компаній,
котрі беруть участь у реалізації "Північного потоку-2", таки запровадять санкції?
Під загрозою опиниться весь проект чи можна буде знайти альтернативу цим компаніям?
У реалізації "Північного потоку-2" беруть участь 627 фірм-підрядників з цілого світу.
Серед них - десятки підприємств дуже вузької спеціалізації,
наприклад, згадані вами прокладальники труб.
Це дуже спеціалізовані фірми, що володіють унікальними технологіями.
Санкції проти таких компаній, щонайменше, дуже сильно сповільнили би реалізацію всього проекту,
а в екстремальному випадку він був би зірваним.
Ви сказали про можливе втручання в європейський суверенітет і необхідність цьому протидіяти.
Що ви маєте на увазі? Чи допускаєте запровадження відповідних санкцій ЄС проти США?
Це залежить від узгодженості дій європейських країн.
Як ви знаєте, і всередині ЄС цей газопровідний проект є суперечливим.
Так що я утримаюся від прогнозу.
Але Німеччина та інші наші великі європейські партнери
неодмінно повинні протидіяти санкціям і, гадаю, докладуть для цього необхідних зусиль.
Проект "Північний потік-2" не тільки економічний.
Він має, як каже німецький уряд, і політичну складову.
"Газпром", зрозуміло, зацікавлений у виключенні України
з системи транзиту російського газу в Європу.
Невже для німецької економіки цей проект настільки важливий,
що інтереси України до уваги не беруться?
Змушений вам заперечити.
Ми не раз публічно говорили, що український транзит нам, як і раніше, потрібен.
Зокрема і з суто економічних причин,
оскільки видобуток газу в Європі сильно скорочується, а без газу не обійтися.
Але ми бачимо і політичний компонент,
тому активно підтримуємо тристоронні переговори - ЄС, Україна, Росія - з цього приводу,
і дуже сподіваємося на конструктивний підхід "Газпрому" для досягнення результату.
Міністр закордонних справ Німеччини Гайко Маас знову захищав "Північний потік-2"
і критикував американську політику санкцій
на щорічному прийомі Східного комітету німецької економіки.
Проте помітно, що політична підтримка цього проекту стає дедалі слабшою.
Ось і зовнішньополітичний експерт фракції соціал-демократів Нільс Шмід
не впевнений у його доцільності.
Як ви гадаєте, чи помер би цей проект без політичної підтримки,
якби при владі в Німеччині нині був інший уряд, і канцлер - не Анґела Меркель?
Не думаю.
Адже "Північний потік-2" відповідає актуальним інтересам не тільки Німеччини,
але й цілого Євросоюзу.
Цей проект різко критикують як деякі консерватори, так і представники інших партій.
Але, наприклад, відомий політик Партії зелених Юрґен Тріттін
належить до прихильників цього проекту.
Як би там не було, думаю, будь-який уряд Німеччини
насамперед враховував би німецькі та європейські інтереси
і, сподіваюся, ухвалив би рішення на користь цього проекту.